a throne that draws blood a previously
unseen prince a weapon with major
significance if you were distracted by
dragons and drama in the new trailer for
house of the dragon keep watching for
some of the finer details
keynote fans may have noticed several
locations from game of thrones in the
new house of the dragon trailer one such
spot should be immediately recognizable
the iron throne it's the seat of power
in westeros forged with dragon fire and
1000 enemy blades when the targaryens
came to power of course littlefinger
points out on game of thrones there
aren't a thousand blades
there aren't even two hundred
i've counted but that clearly hasn't
always been the case this earlier
version of the iron throne takes up a
good part of the red keeps throne room
and the melted blades are featured much
more prominently some decorative blades
are seen almost liquefied and draped
across the stairs leading up to the iron
throne at one point the trailer shows
the hand of viserys the first dripping
blood proving that the swords still have
some bite or it could be a reference to
the way the iron throne is described in
george r.r martin's books as a chair
that exacts a toll on unworthy kings
viewers who know the books may recognize
that this latest trailer showcases
rhaenyra targaryen at two distinct ages
millie alcock portrays the younger
version we see discussing political
strategy with her aunt reinis velarion
and later praying with young alice
hightower the older rhaenyra is played
by emma darcy we also see alison at two
different ages played by emily carey and
olivia cook in a wide-ranging
entertainment weekly preview for house
of the dragon creator ryan j condell
explained how the show will treat its
two timelines condyle revealed that
unlike the events in the books the plot
of house of the dragon will take place
chronologically alcock and carrie will
appear in the early episodes after a
time jump early on in the series darcy
and cook will then play their respective
characters meanwhile it appears that the
older characters like damon targaryen
and king viserys the first will be
played by the same actors throughout the
season
while many of the major characters
showcased in this latest house of the
dragon trailer should already appear
familiar to those who have kept track of
the promotional materials released thus
far one notable character finally
appears in the flesh for the first time
a few quick shots show a blonde man in
combat sporting an eye patch these
physical characteristics clearly
identify him as aemond targaryen fans of
george r r martin's extended a song of
ice and fire universe know that eamond
is the child of king viserys targaryen
the first and alice and hightower
notably eamon is viserys's second oldest
male son but viserys chooses to make
neither amon nor his older brother aegon
targaryen his successor instead choosing
their elder half-sister rhaenyra this
choice divides members of the royal
court into camps i am to inherit the
iron throne
she will block my way also in the books
eamon's eye patch comes from a wound he
got in a fight against rhaenyra's son
lucerus it's physical evidence of
continuing tensions between king
viserys's sons and rhaenyra's immediate
family presumably then ayment will be a
thorn in rhaenyra's side in house of the
dragon
much like the iron throne another
lore-drenched object featured in game of
thrones makes an appearance astute fans
may have noticed the cat's paw dagger
pop up in the house of the dragon
trailer entertainment weekly confirmed
that it is in fact the very same blade
arya uses to slay the night king on game
of thrones before arya receives the
blade it goes through many hands and is
instrumental in setting up some major
events in the original show for one
littlefinger gives this valerian steel
dagger to an assassin who attempts to
kill bran stark that plan obviously does
not go accordingly and eventually it
ends up with arya in the trailer for
house of the dragon this valerian steel
dagger is quickly seen as it is
brandished by alison hightower who yells
about duty and sacrifice as she
approaches rhaenyra targaryen notably
she holds the blade with intent to harm
now they see you as you are
much like in game of thrones it seems
like this particular dagger will be
important to the plot and will be
present at another turning point in the
history of westeros check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about house of the dragon
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]